the Joe Rogan experience so there it's
different you know like they're so
sneaky over there it's yeah I don't know
if it's called sneaky they just they
really want to I bet a okie now as
wishing he would have fought me because
he got knocked out that I by a kickboxer
because they made him fight a kickboxer
and that's what Japan is famous for mmm
they really want to they want to put
fights together that people don't expect
to happen you know we saw hoist fight
the big sumo guy and you know and those
are fights that people talk about for
their once for the ages man look at when
phaidor fought that big what hung man
Choi we still to this day we still to
this day talk about those kind of fights
you know but you know even fate oh I
wouldn't fight Bob Sapp yeah and his
prime is like mother [ __ ] out of here
because when Minotauro got [ __ ]
piledrive yep he was like no no no
that's sudden injury you keep for the
rest of your life yeah Charles neck is
still [ __ ] up to this day it doesn't
make any sense like you sure there's
guys that you can fight but Bob Sapp was
one of the first guys that explode on
the scene that had a lot of athleticism
375 with ABS yeah James Reed 75% clean
dude when I met him like if you stand
next to him you just go wait wait wait
wait what in the [ __ ] are you what are
you what is this new type of human being
yeah he's so big have you ever talked to
him yeah yeah I've talked to him yeah
hey good Zaki kazakh
I was on a bus ride from somewhere in
Tokyo - Saitama Arena and it was like an
hour and twenty minutes he talked the
whole interesting career right yeah he
was a enormous superstar in Japan yeah
normos like it's hard for us to
understand like they were selling dolls
of him and posters and he was huge but
then he ran afoul with k-1 remember
there was this event where they didn't
have a contract for him he was supposed
to fight and he's like where's the
contract you know like it will give you
the contract after the fight he's like
no no I need a contract I need I need to
know what the [ __ ] is happening here and
then he walked out and when he walked
out they decided they were gonna ruin
him yeah it was that night it was they
they were at the venue he's like I'm
still willing to fight just give me the
contract they never gave him the
contract yeah he was telling me that
story the whole time
I was there is that the Yakuza like what
do they do how's that I would imagine
yes some I get the vibe that it is a
little bit you know I don't think much
has changed honest
that's a Power Move you know to let you
know know after the fight we'll give you
the contract like what are you talk yeah
man
no he's and he still he's still like
force and he's still fighting he's still
there I'm like [ __ ] grin for a minute
20 yeah gets tagged with a little one
that's a wrap
he swings he swings until things get
weird no hito he he straight out Tommy
he's like no I tell them it's 60 grand
and I give you a minute 20 at a minute
21 I'm going down I straight up and that
was one of the conversations on the bus
21 I'm going down that is so crazy I
just think it'd take more damage when he
got his orbital broken by cro cop you
remember he like one of his eyes looks
weird yeah he's got like one eye that's
open really wide and it's cuz a cro cop
which is crazy like cro cop was like 220
yeah you know and [ __ ] hit him so hard
with straight left he fractured his eye
socket sap was literally more than 100
pounds bigger than him it was uh was
that with kick boxing gloves on yeah
yeah just gotta fit it in the right hole
that's all it is I think it was
kickboxing I think it was kickboxing
yeah as I recall it was because I don't
think he took him down I think it was a
kickboxing fight well he beat her nesto
who's twice yep which is crazy and who's
tad him really hurt
Doug's shots to the body [ __ ] his legs
over didn't couldn't put it he's
switching his stance I got dropped by
Lake he cited a couple but one or two
times late got back up I was like that
was before he decided the 121 was the
limited well that was when he was 89%
steroids no like his body was so big and
so ridiculous it just rocked up when he
fought Minotauro I remember Eddie Bravo
and I were watching it and he they were
like they show minitor already and they
turned to Bob savvy like Jesus his head
was here and that his neck started right
where his head crests yeah like his neck
went all the way to the edge of his
shoulders like that is the biggest human
being I've ever seen in my life he goes
like just from his ear to his elders
shoulders were cartoonish it was like
the the big boss and a Mike Tyson
punch-out you know yeah video game he
was so big and when he picked up
Minotauro and pile drives almost like oh
my god I know kill him yeah it could
kill him everyone and we're all thinking
like you're not allowed to do that and
they're like in Japan they're like yeah
stomps hey tics they don't give a [ __ ]
have you ever been there to call you've
been there gonna fight you see I think
you have that the crowds changed if I do
the crowds change for the UFC a little
bit because I'm more cheery but they're
still very quiet you know in between
transitions you hear everything it's
weird because you hear the coaches you
hear less got left leg left leg get
through pass through pass through you
hear like the fighter can hear the
opponent can hear it it's very strange
never been to our gym because it's not
quiet at all
yeah we're training it's barn guys are
like coaching it's a [ __ ] I got get up
get up don't let it [ __ ] take you
they're getting on each other but over
there it's so funny my first fight over
there and pride they'd switch my
opponent like six times I showed up and
then finally the original guy was
supposed to fight was a maraca see hilt
help D and ready to fight again he just
shows up to the lane it's just jacked in
[ __ ] yeah I said so I had to fight him
who was it I want to say his name was -
Suki Suki
they call him the Amazon real good
jujitsu guy phenomenal Jitsu guy and um
he swung for an arm around me like in a
minute I'm [ __ ] almost god I was like
belly down trying to escape but had had
that fight been in any other
organization I probably lost because I
could hear crazy Bob and Dave Camarillo
yelling to me hey push the feet off the
face cuz my arm was fully extended he
was bellied down I was bellied down and
I'm like and it was I could hear my
elbows clunk and I can just feel you
know your muscles kind of stretching and
carrying a little bit yeah and I just
started pushing and I could hear them
crystal clear get the feet off your face
get the feet off your face Dave
Camarillo was like in such like can't
blues happen you almost sort of walking
back to the [ __ ] back to the locker
room thinking that I was gonna tap
because I was trying to reach for the
feet and he's yelling put the foot put
to get the feet off your face so I was
able to push and wiggle it out and when
I wiggled it out I swung around for the
e bar in the perfect position I was able
to at the knee bar and the fight and
like that it's like a minute 20 minutes
like that so but it was one of those you
know one of those things that they do in
Japan where the cultures are so
different over there it's really good ii
would pass the guard everyone would
cheer yeah yeah Wow kind of cool but
it's a kana is a little weird when
you're you know you guys are squared up
and you're bouncing around you can hear
from the canvas yeah I'd rather hear the
crowd that's funny I wonder if you get
used to that and then if you go to fight
in the UFC is must be overwhelming for
Japanese guys that are used to fighting
over there with that total quiet and
they come to Vegas it's like just bleed
guys like you they're walking out you're
gonna die yeah you know this it's crazy
[Applause]